there's nothing that i would love more
than just see you live your life and
grow old with someone
kris jenner is making it more than
obvious that she's rooting for kourtney
kardashian and scott disick
to live happily ever after isn't that
wild
in a new clip for thursdays keeping up
with the kardashians chris and courtney
reminisce over the couple's past
relationship you guys look like you're
at the prom
that's really funny to post actually my
prom pic
oh you have to and it doesn't take chris
long to hint to the mom of three
that they could rekindle their
relationship now that so much time has
passed since their split
there's nothing that i would love more
than just see you live your life and
grow old with someone
be happy and content and peaceful
and it would always be so fabulous if it
was the dad
of your children you know
wouldn't that be a dream the couple were
together for nearly 10 years before
officially calling it quits back in
2015.
the two shared three children
eleven-year-old mason
eight-year-old penelope and six-year-old
reign my whole family
for a couple years now love
to just bring up me and scott
getting back together it's frustrating
because
scott and i have had our own private
talks but sometimes i just don't
care to have it just be such a
conversation
all the time so i'll just kind of like
brush it off in a nice way and although
courtney agrees rekindling their romance
would be a dream
she seems to believe it will only be
just that
i think at this stage from what he tells
me
he would love for it to be you and him
he's a talker
i'll marry you right now courtney also
tells chris neither of them have had the
chance to explore the opportunity
i don't think we've really given
ourselves like the time of one of us
like
not being with someone else it looks
like the possibility is even
slimmer now courtney is currently dating
musician travis barker
while scott is also serious with model
amelia hamlin
oh my god just last month courtney and
amelia both attended scott's 38th
birthday party
a source told et that courtney is
unbothered by the relationship
going on to say it's not weird for her
to see them together by any means
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
a source also told e.t in may courtney
hasn't felt this strongly about anyone
in a while
and can see it forever with travis and
despite their past history
scott and courtney have always
prioritized their roles as co-parents
here's what the 38 year old entrepreneur
told et back in 2019.
i mean i think you just gotta figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day i mean there's so many
different things that could pull you in
different directions and you can look
online and instagram social media and
all these things but
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
you want to be comfortable you want to
love the people you're with